في غضون ذلك قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا ان قرار بريطانيا تزويد
اوكرانيا بذخائر تحتوي على يورانيوم منضب
ينم عن تهور مطلق وعدم مسؤوليه وفق
تعبيرها واعتبرت ان الخطوه هي استفزاز
لدفع الصراع في اوكرانيا الى مرحله جديده
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر
انه لا يوجد تصعيد نووي في الحرب
الاوكرانيه وقال انه لا يوجد تصعيد نووي
والدوله الوحيده في العالم التي تتحدث عن
القضايا النوويه هي روسيا وفق تعبيره
واضاف كليفر لي ان تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره التي تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم لا يشكل تهديدا لروسيا وانما يتعلق
فقط بمساعده كيا في دفاع عن نفسها
ان جهته قال رئيس مجلس اياد دوما الروسي
فياتشي سلاف النواش واتباعها يفعلون كل
شيء لاجل ان تستمر الحرب في اوكرانيا
واضاف انه بعد اليورانيوم المنظم يمكن ان
تظهر في اوكرانيا القنابل القذره والاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه وحينها لن يكون هناك
مجال العوده الى الوراء حسب تعبيره واعتبر
فولودين ان قرار بريطانيا مد اوكرانيا
بذخائر مزوده باليورانيوم المنظم سيؤدي
الى كارثه عالميه ستطال الدول الاوروبيه
بالدرجه الاولى